i gotta just come right out of the gate
and say i've been confused
by a couple things because uh
like we spoke on the phone the other day
yes like right after you reached out and
uh i told you
that i had seen you on tmz yeah and that
the story was you just got out of rehab
and that you're sober mm-hmm and uh 40
days yeah and then three days
that's great
the story was also that the rehab you
went to somehow encourages
smoking marijuana yeah well about that
well i went to a detox center first
called vita nova shout out to them um
they don't allow weed out that they just
do the normal uh scheduled things they
do that's in newport beach i was uh they
gave me a scholarship actually so i
don't have to pay
um so i'm very grateful for the people
that vita nova um and i detox for 30
days there got clean so i wasn't
withdrawing when i went to
the other place the place you're
referring to the heavenly center which
is uh steve labelle scott storch the
producer gotcha um and a couple other
people that run it and the heavenly
center aka you know abbreviated thc you
know they don't force you to smoke weed
uh you know they don't like like you
know like say you have to smoke weed to
like get better they just say if it
helps it helps
and i'm not a big wheat smoker myself
um that's what confuses me
but more because we saw we went back and
looked at that actual tmz clip
where uh they they i guess you were on
hollywood boulevard or something i was
at bulls steakhouse boys yeah and you
said in that clip to tmz you're like i'm
a big pot guy
i don't know
okay okay okay i'm gonna come clean i
smoke a blood like maybe every like i
smoke two blunts a week but i was maybe
i was just i was trying to like
whatever i'm not mad at you i'm just
like i was kind of i was kind of trying
to shout out the heavenly center more
because they reposted it so i wanted
them to think that yeah like the it
helped me out a lot but then just
yesterday
like you like you posted this thing with
like like i i ate edibles and i got so
suited and loaded oh no no no that that
scripted that was scripted uh i just did
a collaboration with uh my good friends
uh that that make edibles and weed
called gassy and uh and that was more of
like and we did a scripted thing i i
don't i don't eat edibles i'll end up at
the hospital on edibles you know what i
mean and uh we just did a a
collaboration for uh kefworld joints and
delta eight gummies so they paid me to
make that whole skit where i'm going in
to in and out and perfectly entertaining
i'm sure you're performing but i didn't
eat i didn't eat any of that but uh i
did i do i did smoke a couple of the
joints but it's not like my main thing
like i mean
can i ask
what was your main thing when you said
you were like a detoxing like what were
your detox
when i went to vita nova i was coming
off of probably taking uh
20 nothing there was no fentanyl in my
system by the way uh why is that a rumor
that's going around they had fun no no
no i'm just saying that there wasn't
because usually people get fake [ __ ] you
know what i mean everything's fake does
anybody take fentanyl on purpose yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it seems like
it's all these like fake pills where
they're they cut with fennel they're the
blue they're little blue uh
perk 30s are like the most commonly
faked ones why i had a guy yesterday
that was he was in rehab he's like i
just went in there and he's like
everything's cut with it anyway so i
might as well just do fentanyl he's like
if that makes sense i'm like that
doesn't make any sense at all the
problem with these fake pills is like at
first people didn't like them because
they wanted what they wanted you know
what i mean but now they like they like
say like they like xanax so when they
were getting fake xanax they didn't like
it but now
that the xanax has fentanyl in it
they're they they like the fentanyl and
they're getting addicted to a whole
nother substance opiates how common is
it to have fentanyl in something that
people it is probably
the things being sold in la right now i
would say 95 percent of everything is uh
every drug is cut with uh fentanyl
something like the fake pill where they
press in yeah but it's cocaine it's it's
everything
that's what killed my friend mac miller
it was uh fentanyl ace cocaine can you
help us understand why
on
[ __ ] uh
is it like
like
cocaine and fentanyl
it's like it's like it's what they used
to cut it you know what i mean like how
they like baby lacks a different powder
now they're doing fentanyl to make it
stronger it makes it it makes your
product a little stronger but what the
problem is is this is like you know with
the labs wherever they [ __ ] make it
someone adds
two pounds more of the wrong batch and
then you've got a deadly batch that's
gonna hit the streets you know what i
mean like they they they miscalculate
because they're in jungles they're not
in the laboratory
whoops [ __ ] yeah whoops i put a
teaspoon in now
i wonder if they're trying to make
people addicted to fentanyl you know
like get them off the coke and slowly
introduce fentanyl and then all you're
selling because fun fact fentanyl back
like 20 years ago was like a very niche
drug it was only used as like anesthesia
and pain medicine like open heart
surgery yeah people out for longer
uh on a patch and they would put them
yeah
it was the pain people would like chew
the patch instead of having yes that
taxi out started but like like if you
would have went into a hospital 20 years
ago or no not a hospital a rehab and
said they would have been like what are
you addicted to and said fentanyl they
would have been like
what is that what did you get that like
you know what i mean yeah but
you didn't finish what you're saying
what would you go in for your 20
milligrams i was taking about 20
vicodins or what they call them
hydrocodones uh now and uh about 10 10
xanax today but everything was real
because i was paying out of pocket for
like old people on hospice's scripts and
you know because i i don't like fentanyl
i've never been addicted to fentanyl
myself what's old people on hospice like
you know like like uh like you're
getting prescribed legit stuff at a
legit business versus like scoring on
the street because they have like one or
two years left to live and
they want to make extra money so they
sell it and stuff what's what's the
detox like uh from xanax is it like
vertigo i heard it's kind of like your
vision flip it's like okay like i've
i've detoxed at my at my worst was
probably november of 2020 um i actually
was smoking uh perk 30s um real perk
dirty still not fentanyl and i was
taking
20 fake exams a day that i later found
out were laced with heroin in it and i
remember uh looking in the mirror one
day and just being like if i keep doing
this i'm gonna die like i could already
start seeing like my cheekbones go in
and stuff
and um i'm sorry what was the the
question cause like when you're detoxing
off opiates you're kind of like flu-like
symptoms you're sick you're nauseous
yeah it's like xanax is like okay oh
yeah uh i would much rather withdraw off
opiates than xanax because
um uh the two drugs that you can
actually die from withdrawals from are
alcohol and xanax because you can have
seizures
oh and you started having seizures right
you were talking about that oh no last
time i had a seizure was uh november of
2020. i haven't had uh any okay and was
that seizure from quitting uh going cold
turkey off of xanax right opiate opiate
oh i don't want to say opiates like you
can lock someone in a room for like 10
days they're going to go through hell
but they're not going to die yeah right
you know what i mean
necessarily i have hunger or something
like that yeah yeah it's hungry you
don't feel that withdrawal's not going
to kill you it's like you know they
don't have
water yeah they're gonna they're gonna
die but um yeah so i went in for about
20 narcos a day and and 20 real zans no
fentanyl in my system and it was a
smooth process
it went well it was a nice facility i i
did i attended therapy and yoga and
what brought about the
decision to go in there was it like
there was an intervention on you it
actually came uh
from just me wanting to change uh i cuz
um
i felt like you know i'm 25 now and i i
just couldn't do it anymore because i
don't want to be because when you go
into those rehab centers there's people
in their 50s that i've been there
hundreds of times and they owe and i've
been to seven you know in the last like
year
and um they always tell me the same
thing you don't want to be this age in
here you want to nip it in the butt when
first you're younger i got sober when i
was 33 you know something something like
yeah
yeah so this time i i know i'm i'm so
strong-headed i know i have it this time
i would have loved to have gotten it
sooner than 33
and um
strong
headed
be careful with that yeah because like
what it is is uh surrendered you know
like being no you have to you have to be
selfish uh completely selfish to
yourself and surrender to the program
right that my dad is actually the one
that told me surrender to the program
because he was addicted to meth uh for
three years like five years ago he's
been sober ever since
so uh he relates a little bit and he
told me this time you just gotta
surrender completely to the program and
i did this time and i it it helped out
tremendously i feel i feel really good
good i'm way past the withdrawals
um my skin is finally getting healthier
looking you know like good man
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass
like the general anesthesia bike ride
the vasectomy olympics and sky jacking
the footage is so intense we have full
grown men passing out at almost every
city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]